so thanks I'm from the government I'm
here to help
uh so I'm Sheldon I'm from NASA
headquarters wait I don't get a whoop
Microsoft
so we have a whole team at NASA
headquarters actually working it's
called The Open Source science
initiative and we have the transform to
open science mission
let's see
there we go so I have done a lot of
different stuff in my career uh I'm an
oceanographer but I take a lot of
pictures with different types of robots
because I'm down at jet propulsion
laboratory a lot uh I use robot sale
boat vehicles to go and do cruises up in
the Arctic uh I led a proposed new NASA
Mission uh
and I started as an oceanographer with
NASA instruments NASA's whole Suite of
satellites that are looking downwards at
the Earth to monitor weather and climate
and that's where my career started
mostly in Fortran and Matlab which is
you know really where a lot of science
is still at and about 2018 I went to a
workshop sort of you know like this and
I it was a pangea Workshop which is an
open science community that was for
computational oceanography
and I was like oh crap this is like a
meteor type extension Extinction event
in science if I don't learn how to do
this right now so I dropped everything I
learned python and I immediately joined
numb Focus because I saw all the
libraries that I love were being
supported by num Focus
and then in 2000 just a little while
later uh I moved to client Computing I
started doing this new type of science
that was more inclusive and
that really changed how I approached
science and how I saw a lot of the
barriers because I've always been at
small institutions at small commercial
companies and non-profits doing science
outside of Academia and
those barriers to doing science and
doing you know research are real and
it's hard to overcome and so that's sort
of why we started tops is to try and
break down a lot of those barriers
so I want to talk about some of these
amazing scientific discoveries so 2016
the first gravitational wave that
protected 1.3 billion years ago which
two black holes collided
which physicals in the space-time fabric
yeah
thousands of people collaborating
together with ligo thousands of
researchers working together to get this
incredible
the focus
another Discovery you might recognize
this picture
right so this is the first image of a
black hole
and this was just about a year and a
half two years ago the first image of a
black hole there's Katie Dr Katie Balvin
and uh we're deeply grateful for all the
open source contributors you know all of
their work was on GitHub in the open
this was an image I believe favorite cat
Butler yeah
and the algorithms they were using the
software that they were using
accelerated their work so that they were
able to do this
within years and years of additional of
effort
so another James Webb Space Telescope
which has been in the news a lot
of Amazing Discoveries are sort of
coming out at this pace that's
incredible and part of that's because of
the early release Science Program where
some of the sense of the images are
being released immediately without any
embargo and that's a little unusual in
science a lot of times when you collect
data
some people don't share it and some
people most NASA data you have to share
so if you're getting funded by NASA
you're required to share your data
sometimes it's 12 months after
collection sometimes it's at publication
but you are required to share it that's
not true of all science but James Webb
has early release so that the data is
available immediately
and here's an image
this is the first one of the first
images from James Webb and arfon Smith
wrote a really nice blog post basically
talking about how the core data pipeline
the simulation tools that astronomers
are using the tools that they all who
use and here's you know Astro PI right
here
these are the heart of these new
discoveries and The Innovation that jwst
is going to lead to
and here's one of the results that came
out just last month this is the first
carbon dioxide on an exoplanet for the
first time and you can see it in the
plot right here this is pretty
incredible and co-author Dr Natasha
pathala is saying you know NASA's open
science guiding principles centered in
this early release work because this
data is available we were able to get
references on but it wasn't just one or
two people they had a slack group with
371 people all collaborating together
and instead of fighting over this image
and trying to see who could publish it
first they worked together and they
published it all together and they
published it open access
so I mean these are pretty amazing
discoveries right like all of science
right
so you're going to be doing science you
want to go can we build on and extend
results all that work that science is
doing there's billions of dollars that
are being funded by the federal agencies
science
those results of the scientists are
publishing can we test them so Victoria
Stodden tested 204 scientific papers
published in Triple A house Journal
science so basically the top journal for
scientists you want to publish a big
result that's where you go
can you so she took 204 papers this is
just in 2018 so it's not like 10 years
ago
uh can you get the data can you
reproduce the results
sixty percent of the authors even though
it's required
60 percent
can you from those that you could get
the data could you reproduce the results
74 of them the methods that were
described in the paper were sufficient
to reproduce
and that's a failure that's a failure of
science that means that we're publishing
results that other people can't take a
yoga
can we rapidly iterate and resolve
problems so this is actually one of the
first things I worked on I'm not that
old I'm not 199 years old but in 1998 so
satellite data it comes down it's
actually you know it's pretty
complicated to interpret it comes down
uncalibrated it makes compressed
followers
upper ocean temperature
this uh satellite is measuring the upper
atmosphere
and in 1990 uh scientists published a
result from singular satellite and put
them all together and created a long
time series and they said
the upper atmosphere is cooling
therefore all global warming holes were
gone
and we can't make policy about global
warming we can't try to like change
people's behavior because the models
aren't correct because we have the
satellite data that shows the upper
atmosphere is Cooling and that's against
what all the global warming models are
saying so it was actually the birth of
this climate denial
then in 1998 they found out oh
sorry we forgot about the solar wind and
there's a positional friction you could
see it
the satellite was as it was slowing down
it was slowly going a little bit lower
just a tiny bit and that changed the
angle that it was looking at and that
changed temperature
oh sorry
is that do you want me to stay right
here is that better
Okay so they found this error in the
analysis and they were able to fix it it
was pretty straightforward it was just
nobody was trying to be malicious it was
an error in the code but because the
code wasn't shared even though the data
was open it was really difficult even
though they found this discovery it took
an additional five years and a bunch of
funding for them to rewrite all of this
code again
and then find that oh the upper
atmosphere is actually warming
and the global warming models are
measuring that correctly or modeling
that correctly but that's 13 years after
these papers that's delaying the
response to climate change for 13 years
if that code had been open it would have
been much faster because there would
have been more eyes on it and these
types of small little errors and these
really complicated algorithms
are really common right I mean everyone
knows you write a line of code and for
everyone you write there's probably two
different ones that have errors in them
which is why open software is so
important
so also like who gets to participate in
science
so can anyone participate this is access
to journals worldwide so most science is
published in scientific journals still
and your citation rate is a measure of
your uh impact on science so the lighter
colored countries have more institutions
that have subscribed to the Wiley
subscription service so they get free
access to journals
I was never at any of these institutions
so I ran into the paywalls that you get
all the time uh so often that I had a
friend finally like make me an Adjunct
professor somewhere so that I would stop
emailing him for articles
it's nice it looks good on a resume
right but uh
but that was because I had access and I
had a friend to reach out to not
everyone has that and not everyone's in
one of these countries that can afford
these really incredibly expensive
subscriptions so
what happens to the rest of the world
when they just run into paywall after
paywall after paywall how do they
participate in science
is it a Level Playing Field you know is
science fair we like to think that it's
fair
we like to think that we aren't biased
on the left is a dual Anonymous peer
review analysis done by NASA
where we looked at so non-dapper means
it's just a peer review you get a
proposal in you put it through peer
review
and NASA kept seeing that uh we didn't
have the numbers to do uh people of
color but we did have just enough
numbers to look at gender
so looking at gender we kept finding the
proposals by women pis were funded at a
lesser rate than those by male pis
so there's you know maybe it's a younger
group of people proposing who are less
experienced so maybe the proposals just
aren't as good from women pis or maybe
there's a bias so let's take the names
off of the proposals and then put them
through the panel review
and when it turns out when you take the
names off of the proposals women have a
higher success rate than men
and this was repeated for several
different years
so before that we had tried everything
we showed people via videos about
implicit bias
we showed we talked about biases before
we did the panel reviews we added
younger people we had more diverse
review panels nothing changed that
statistic until we took the name off of
The Proposal
so there is some bias and more NASA
proposals are now being reviewed this
way
is there racism in panel reviews so you
have people reviewing these proposals so
a paper just came out yesterday uh for
looking at NSF where it appears to be a
systematic racism that's reflected in
the grand allocations that's coming
through the panel reviews
so it's not a Level Playing Field and
it's something that science needs to
work on
but why is it that way
so part of it is how we do science it's
the local data so instead of using
cloud-based data is pretty new most
federal agencies are moving there really
quickly but for a long time part of the
problem is that we were only using local
data and that's part of why it made it
really hard to reproduce all of our
results you had to bring the data to you
it took I mean these are petabytes of
data sometimes sometimes just terabytes
but it's months to download if there's a
new version okay start again
that discourages external collaborations
and it reins it reinforces this
institutional Advantage again it's much
harder for someone to just decide to
look at the climate in their area it's
much harder for them to do that analysis
if they have to be at a big institution
with these big data resources
we also in science there is a long
tradition of closed software most people
do not share their software and that
makes it redundant it makes it error
prone it impedes advancement in
Innovation and again it reinforces
closed science and a closed way of doing
things that make it really hard to
reproduce results
you're not required to share your code
some journals now at publication are
starting to require that but it's it's
pretty common in most science to not
share your code there's also this local
infrastructure where you're running on
compiler-specific operating systems in
unique environments and again it just I
used to go and work in Denmark every
summer so I could work on their super
computer like it
you shouldn't have to like fly over to
like get on somebody's system to use it
uh but my kids really did like
Copenhagen
who doesn't like Copenhagen uh paywall
publishing again you know these these
paywalls these journals that are
charging for people to look at federally
funded science it restricts access to
knowledge it perpetuates exclusionary
practices and it reinforces
institutional and privileges
and we're looking ahead at these really
really big challenges
we know that we need more we science
rather than me science
we can't afford the luxury of putting
ourselves first we have to put science
first we have to put the community first
we have to put working together first
and we know also that we need more
people
it is not just numbers it's not we just
need more people we need more people
with diverse points of view
we need with diverse experiences to
participate so we ask the best questions
and we find the best Solutions and this
isn't just let's all be a Kumbaya moment
let's be friends there is a lot of
evidence both from business from science
diverse teams are more successful
diverse teams find Solutions faster
diverse teams get better more impactful
solutions
there's there's so much evidence out
there now that if you have a not diverse
team you're not going to get the result
that you should get it's not going to be
as impactful and so we know we need
these diverse experiences
and so what can we do about this
we can move to the cloud right so we can
have cloud-based data so that our
results are reproducible easy to access
it broadens participation because then
anybody can access it especially NASA's
no you know and many of the federal
agencies they're putting their data on
the cloud without egress fees
so it's basically public data it's just
acceptable because you're bringing your
compute and there's many different ways
to get on the cloud for free I found
every single one of them
uh now I have a hub but you know before
that uh open software you know we really
need to move to open software and I
think all of you are the experts in this
room on helping scientists move in that
direction and that's part of the reason
I'm here is sort of a plea for help and
a call for Action from these communities
to come and work more with the
scientific community so that we can
learn from you and all your experiences
about governance and all your
experiences about open software and how
you build that community and we know
it's not easy building Community is
often messy and it's often difficult and
it's hard work but it's worth it and
open software is going to speed up
science
foreign
we also the open cyber infrastructure
the science data platform so like this
is an example of uh this is from a paper
I published called science storms the
cloud and it's sort of how my workflow
changed when I started working on the
cloud where I would just go through a
web interface and I could be anywhere
during covet I got out my kids Raspberry
Pi and on this 30 computer
I think I had 80 workers and 250
gigabytes of data running an analysis on
a little 30 computer it was you know fun
for me
um so then you authenticate yourself and
you probably know this you go and you go
to a Jupiter Hub and you get all of your
favorite software libraries and then
your data is right there and you can run
these analyzes so quickly and it's all
reproducible and shareable because you
have your code on GitHub you send
somebody a mybinder link and they're
doing your same analysis
foreign
also like publishing in open executable
notebooks
you know publishing your scientific
results especially if you're already on
GitHub using jupyter notebooks it makes
it really easy to create just a research
notebook and share this it's executable
and it's free for anyone to look at and
use and reproduce your results
so part of this is like on us as a
community to like change how we're doing
science using all of these amazing open
source tools and we know that open
science is more accessible reproducible
and inclusive open science we also the
evidence is overwhelming it creates
research that cited more it creates a
bigger impact it increases transparency
and it generates more collaborations and
that means more collaborative projects
it's also really important that this
provides access to Hidden knowledge
there's a lot of knowledge in science
and you know the same thing when you
start to use a new library sometimes the
documentation isn't what you wish it is
there's a lot of hidden knowledge and
the more that we write those down and we
provide that documentation for anyone it
creates more Equitable systems and it
increases participation
and so what does big government do well
like why is NASA moving into this space
I would be like both excited and scared
if I were you
uh
NASA has this
giant portfolio there's hundreds of
missions
it's not just Earth we go to the sun we
go to exoplanet we monitor exoplanets
we're going to other planets
we monitoring deep space the beginnings
of time there are missions researching
Quantum science uh government is really
good at organizing moving slowly and
starting to fund things substantially in
a way so that we provide stability
and that can be really good and NASA now
sees like open source science open
source software is something that's
becoming so critical to science that we
can't ignore it anymore
so we have a new initiative called The
Open Source science initiative it's
funded at 20 million dollars per year
this initiative has four different
elements the first is policy super
exciting
sorry Steve Crawford if he's watching
sorry it's really exciting
um policy is though it was it's a lot
what's allows us to do this uh it's
creating the ecosystem that we do
science in it's creating the rules so
that people will share software will
share data it's the Cyber infrastructure
and supporting the development of the
open cyber platforms so the open like
Jupiter hubs and how all those science
data platforms are going to involve
we know that we can't rely on volunteer
efforts anymore so doing the
infrastructure funding we have a number
of different funding elements that we
are now supporting open source software
libraries we're supporting moving uh
closed code to open code we're
supporting the community transformation
and we're doing Outreach through the
transform to open science project
some of the exciting proposed new
policies are uh that we're changing how
the requirements about data software and
Publications and we're making these so
that publishing this is the proposed new
policy that we anticipate being released
within the next month
uh but it is not final at this time but
publishing Open Access with no embargo
and it's software so remember that story
that I told you about the mission
software how it took 13 years for it to
get fixed because it was closed Mission
software is still closed that hasn't
changed so this new policy says that
mission software needs to be open
and Mission data is going to be open
with no period of exclusive access so
now those early results from those
images that are released from jwst now
that's going to apply to all new
missions and all their data
and the transform to open science so
this is a 40 million dollar five-year
mission to accelerate the adoption of
open science we have three strategic
goals to support 20 000 scientists
moving to get an open science badge so
that they learn about open science at a
double participation by historically
excluded groups across all of NASA
science and to enable five major
breakthroughs tops is across all of NASA
so it's across astrogelio planetary
biological physical and Earth sciences
and we are doing this through four
different areas we're looking at
engagement capacity sharing which is
developing open science resources
incentives so we want to change the
incentives in science so that open
science activities are recognized and
rewarded and we're coordinating with
other agencies
the declare 2023 NASA's year of open
science where we're going to have we're
going to be everywhere I'm going to get
a lot of airplane points and we're going
to have high level visibility and
conferences we're doing virtual cohorts
and summer schools and we have targeted
workshops we're going to be at all of
these conferences
really try and there's this momentum
that's happening right now I mean this
room is filled with people who are doing
open source software and open science
and this momentum is not just in the U.S
it's a global momentum it's happening in
Europe it's happening in Asia there is a
big un report that came out about two
years ago about open science they're
Germany just recognized so federally
funded projects in Germany they're
recognizing software as part of their
reviews
NASA will start recognizing open source
activities as part of their reviews in
the future this is there is momentum
across agencies across the world moving
towards open science and it's all been
enabled by development of Open Source
software libraries and the people like
you
and we need you we need more of you and
we need to work more closely with you
okay my kids made this and I'm trying to
get them more views on YouTube
uh I did it my own YouTube video and
they they I like this they're in seventh
grade he's taking a video class I did my
YouTube video and I got some less than
kind feedback from my son
foreign
so he made this video for us to
advertise our project and I thought it
was really great because it's to me it
seems really inspirational and I didn't
give him any directions but he's just
heard me talk about how passionate I am
about changing science so it's more
Equitable and that more people can
participate and that's his video I will
upload these slides uh this afternoon to
my Twitter account I'll put a link
because we do them on zenodo so you'll
have access to all these slides
and there's a lot of different ways that
you can get involved with this project
there's an email list there's a website
we have a monthly forums where we talk
about different open science topics we
have a GitHub repository where
discussions are enabled and again I'll
upload these to zenodo and put out a
link to them on Twitter later today
so thank you very much
and I wanted to make sure to leave time
for questions so if you have questions I
think you can ask them and then I'll
repeat them so that people online can
hear
uh yeah in the back so if we've already
got some Open scores code that we've
been working on that I don't know that
it's redundant anywhere for science
um
does that do we just follow this and
check out your slides like how do we
kind of start collaborating with you to
get food into your hands
well if your code's on GitHub it's
halfway there right
so what you would want to do is probably
reach out to different NASA science
teams and one way to do that would be to
find out so one of the requirements of
the new policy I get like okay policy I
find it less than exciting but it is
incredibly important because this new
policy is requiring all science meetings
to be open
so a lot of times if you develop
software it's really hard to know where
the community is where they're meeting
now all of those meetings are going to
be open to the public
so that they'll be advertised and you
can find out about them you can attend
and uh so I would uh
join tops like the email list we have
lots of notifications of different uh
people come and speak at the monthly
forums and what I would do is try to
reach out to us and we can uh connect
you within NASA
I think in the front yeah yes so thank
you very much for the presentation it
was very interesting
um so I'm all for opencide is an open
software and I think it's not fake in
this room but at the same time I see
that it's a bit who else in the sense
that some journals are changing like
nine thousand dollars for example to
what is a single Paper
and I'm wondering how these policies can
help with systemic change in Academia
how citations are measured how success
is measured and so forth which causes
all sorts of Mental Health crisis right
so I would like to ask you what do you
think about that and how the government
can help
so uh right now if you want to publish
Open Access article in nature I believe
it's twelve thousand dollars
uh many of the journals that used to
charge about five or six hundred dollars
for publishing in them are now charging
eighteen hundred dollars because they're
forcing you to go open access they've
now made it a requirement and so they've
more than tripled the price and they're
saying well but it's open because you
you it's the government set the
government said we have to do that
so how open science actually works is
very nuanced because there's been a lot
of comments so I was at
a conference in La Jolla yesterday that
this same question came up
and one of the big things that we've
heard is for the rest of the world if
you're not funded by NASA or NSF or NIH
one of the big federal agencies
you may not be able to afford to publish
any longer
so while Open Access sounds great
there's a lot of nuances in how it's
implemented so that we actually broaden
participation in science so there's
different ways to do that and there's
working with the journals so that
there's right now most journals have
waivers that if you're from a certain
list of countries you can publish
without paying the fee you could also
apply to not pay a fee
I think that there's also a
responsibility on us and this is where
the metrics come in and as a community
we have alternatives
we just aren't valuing them
so you can publish in an executable
Jupiter book you can get a DOI for that
publication and people can cite your
work and they can reproduce it but right
now that's not seen as valuable as a
publication in nature or science our
community isn't valuing it so part of
what we need to do is find out new
metrics for Science and as a community
say we want more people to participate
we want to give them recognition and we
can't have twelve thousand dollars to
publish be the only way that we provide
incentives
so this is this Open Access requirement
that the Nelson memo that Kate so
there's a big osdp a White House memo
that came out in August called The
Nelson memo this is asking all federally
funded agencies to develop a plan so
that by
2025 2025 all of their fund funded res
all of their funded projects will have
open access Publications built into them
so we have some time to figure this out
and so now it's been announced that this
is going to be the way it is if it's
federally funded it's going to be open
access we've got a few years to make
sure that it's equitable and there's a
lot of people talking about this right
now and thinking about how we're going
to do that part of this is going to be
the science Community the software
Community deciding what metrics we're
going to use and how we're going to
Value each other's work
talk about
what they are I'm wondering what is that
maybe college or endorsement
is there anything really you know solid
there or is just you know it would be
nice
so the question was uh on the slide that
I showed that from the Victoria Stodden
paper in 2018 that 60 of the people
weren't sharing their data and the
question was well
they said they were going to share you
know is there any enforcement mechanism
so most federally funded research is
funded through grants which are
considered a gift to the public good
so no
uh now you have to so the journals when
they're publishing they are agreeing
that they will share their data but if
they don't there's no enforcement
mechanism
now what's happening is in the review
process papers won't get published until
so many of the journals are shifting
this now because of this paper because
of these results where people said just
contact the author and then the author
would never respond to your email
okay and there could be many reasons for
that but but yeah so many of the
professors were responding to emails so
uh now many journals are requiring you
to have your data in a repository and
have it be public before they will
publish your paper
and it's okay during the review process
for some of these journals to say you
know here it's all set up it's not going
to be public until this is accepted
but most many journals now do require
that as a condition for publication
many of the agencies now are moving
towards these open data requirements
where you have to have a data management
plan you have to document and say
exactly when how and where you're going
to release your data and make it public
so it's moving in a direction of
enforcement
through the publication is the main way
of enforcing it because the federally
funded grants it's difficult to enforce
unless you know if you're going to go up
for another Grant the grant officer
might look back and see whether or not
you did what you said on the other Grant
so
yeah yeah
sorry afro biotech company so I think my
work standpoint I'm just curious are you
guys
uh for this initiative
we're coming right out of an election
here there's always this sort of idea
that like a little knowledge is the
dangerous
to have like that um residency to do the
black hole photograph into that because
people were like oh
so I'm curious how that sort of
education is
kind of resistance but
not yet
yeah so the question was about
coordination with other federal agencies
and while being open also led to the
harassment of Dr Katie Bauman uh and so
first yes we are coordinating with other
federal agencies and I would anticipate
an announcement in January about the
specific agencies
I believe in the first two weeks of the
year and again there is a momentum
across all of the federal agencies to
move towards open science
uh and with regards to the harassment of
Dr Katie Bauman and that was really
really hard to see I think for all of us
because what one of the things that I
remember reading was people went through
the GitHub repository and they counted
the lines that she had committed and
then and then her other colleagues had
to step up and say no she's you know
she's cloned this repository and then
she contributed it
yeah yeah sometimes it's hard to be a
woman in science
uh I would say that uh unfortunately you
know that is not the exception for women
in science uh I think that the barriers
are very real and they often
unfortunately usually they come out in
private in smaller meetings Katie had a
very public
uh way to uh it came out very publicly
but that that's those same biases and
discrimination harassment both towards
women and I think people of color are
very very real and you can see them in
those panel reviews
one more question yeah hi I'm curious I
can ask people
uh coming from Academia and works
research
you know people are often not their
primary expertise is in there
and they write code that hopefully
doesn't have errors in it
it does and then and then if they're
asked to share it or publish it a lot of
times what goes out is something that
can't be run anywhere other than their
machine even if they're using 100 open
source uh tools is there any
work or policy towards increasing either
availability of you know research
software engineers in Academia or
training training or
students bis to you know actually put
out codes
so part of tops is this we're starting
with open science training and we're
also looking to provide additional
science training we recognize that there
are a lot of tools in science not just
computational tools but also in
management and like
developing kind and inclusive
environments that you there's no class
on running a meeting in graduate school
just like they're like the only
programming class I had was lisp in like
1992.
um so yeah we are working to provide
additional resources uh I think that
what's changing though is that rather
than asking people to spend a lot of
time becoming really skilled in an area
that they're maybe not trained in or not
that comfortable in
what's changed is that the open source
tools have actually made it so much
easier to do reproducible science that
you don't have to become an expert that
if you can just use a docker you know or
if you understand how to use if you're
on a science platform where you know
you've created an environment file those
things are making it more reproducible
and we we also need to recognize that we
don't maybe need to reproduce or have
everything be executable
that's simply releasing your software is
actually really valuable even with all
of it
okay lack of documentation lack of
comments the variable names are like xx1
x1a X2
and I know because we just gave some of
my code to some students to redo and
they were like what the heck
it was a test
um but but even that is super valuable
right it's because it's a record of what
went into a publication and what
interviewers alone and although you
would love for it to be commented and
well written and executable even just
having that code is a step forward
so it and it is effort to make it
executable so maybe the first time you
publish it
nobody you know maybe only one other
student is using it but then if it does
become a more important piece of
software then that's the time maybe to
invest more effort in commenting your
code and making it executable
so thank you thank you everyone it was
really nice
[Applause]